Good morning everyone. Thanks for making time on a Thursday,
especially during lunchtime after a long week at
Reinvent.
We're, we're really glad you're here. Uh, just a
quick show of hands, uh, also proof of life.
Has anyone heard about Gen AI this week
here at Reinvent?
Yeah, so you're definitely not alone. There's been over
$200 billion invested in Gen
AI startups.
But the sad truth is that a lot of those
investments aren't actually making all their way
into production.
So, I'm Eric Anderson, I'm a principal
solutions architect here at AWS and I
help some of our most strategic customers with their AI
strategy, and I'm joined here by my colleagues.
Hey everyone, I'm Nicola.
I'm a start-up solution architect.
I work with healthcare and life science startups
out of Australia and New Zealand.
And I'm Jeffrey Hammond. Uh, I am an ISV
product strategist. I work with our
software company customers to help identify
how AWS can help you be more profitable
and drive profitable growth.
So over the next 60 minutes, the three of us will go
through 6 proven design strategies that will
help make sure that you're not the right, on the wrong
side of that
statistic.
But first, in order to help us along, we've got a fictional
software company that's in the healthcare space
that we'll be referring to throughout the presentation.
So picture this, a successful B2B customer
that was designed to handle everything for
healthcare companies,
from scheduling
to doctor's notes, all the
things like that, and their CEO woke up
one morning and he said,
hey, our competitors have AI in our products,
we should do that too.
So we went to his technical team and said,
I'll give you 3 months to build something with AI.
So what did our well-meaning but ill
ill-advised team do?
They build a chatbot, of course, because, you know,
who doesn't need something to go out and answer questions.
The only problem was the chatbot
started getting creative with appointment scheduling,
and so it created appointments that didn't even
exist. And I don't know about you, I'd
be a little upset if I appeared at a doctor's appointment
on a Saturday and the office was closed,
so it wasn't really the ideal
situation, but it actually gets better or
worse depending on your perspective.
So they kind of forgot to monitor any of the
costs, and it actually was costing them
$50 to provide this capability,
and they weren't charging their customers at all in
order to do so.
Fortunately, this is just a hypothetical
situation and no one actually showed up to
the doctor's office on a Saturday,
but some of the lessons that this company can learn,
I think you can take back to yours as well as you
go back to your companies after reinvent.
But whether you're a data scientist, a developer,
you focus on product strategy, or the
technical details, we really want you
all to come out of here with something that you can take back,
and it really does take all those roles
in order to make sure that you're successful.
You need the right use cases, the right technical
details, the right pricing strategy, which we'll get
into in a lot more detail.
And with that, I'll hand it over to Jeffrey to go into
a bit more detail.
Yeah, so, as, as you mentioned, uh,
Eric, uh, the spend
is, is, is pretty significant, uh, in this
space. $192
billion has been poured into AI startups by investors,
uh, so far in, uh, in, in 2025,
and, uh, we anticipate that
by 2029,
uh, the, uh, uh, software spend is gonna
grow to over $114
billion.
We did a survey earlier this year with
Forrester Research and we went out and asked over
640 software
companies about their spend plans with
respect to generative AI,
and what we found was that
over
60%
have significantly increased their
R&D budget. So the money is
there, it's being spent. I think we all know that.
But here's where it starts to worry
us a little bit. In that same survey, one
of the things that uh that Forrester asked
was, well,
what are your priorities? Why are you spending this
money? What do you, what do you hope to accomplish?
Top answers were things like, well, we want
to increase our brand awareness. CEO wants
to be thought of as an AI native company,
uh, growing revenue, which is good on its on
it's. Its face reducing
costs
at the bottom of the list, and there are about 1010
or 11 answers were things like
we want to improve our customer support or
we want to enhance our user experience.
That's a little bit of an alarm bell for me
because if you think of what we should be
doing with these technologies, if we're not
improving the way that our customers use our
product. The
way that that we're reducing their
toil, then
in some ways I think we're we're we're putting
the cart before the horse. And so when we
think about how to be successful when you're going
from prompt to product,
putting that customer experience front and
center, working backward from the customer
is actually the thing that should be the highest priority
as you start to think about your opportunities.
I think we see the results in some of the
latest surveys and
information that have come out.
According to 451
Research, they did a survey of about 1000
IT in line of business professionals, and
one of the things that they found was 42% of those
companies had abandoned the majority
of their AI initiatives before they reached
production.
At the same time, 46% of
those projects have been scrapped between
the proof of concept phase
and, uh, scaling broad adoption
now. If I were to take
that stat and be the glass half
full person, that's actually a good thing
because you don't want to go all the way
to scaling and roll out in full
production to discover that you can't drive profitable
growth. So it's good that we're weeding out
things before we go the whole way
through the effort. To me, the glass half empty
here though is that we're not,
we're putting things into. POC, which
should never
get out of POC, and we should be finding more
effective ways to separate the
high value business cases use cases
that we're going to work on
from the marginal value use
cases so that we can put all
of our focus and all of our spend behind the things
that have the highest degree of success
and the highest ability to drive profitable
growth. So how
do we do that? How does generative AI
create business value?
Nicola, I'm going to turn that over to you.
Thanks Jeffrey, so
what are some of those really core strengths
of generative AI that you can really
use to generate business value?
Generating content, of course it's in the name,
probably the most obvious,
you know, think of images for retail
websites, hyper personalized marketing,
I know myself, I've used some to craft
some of those trickier customer responses,
ah so you're probably already using it yourselves
either in a personal or professional setting
in this way. Code
generation and execution is another really
core strength.
There are many applications for, for
actually for this,
so I think to our first example of
creating appointments and booking these to
generating sequel for business intelligence
use cases,
um, code generation and
execution with secure guard rails
is a really, really important
strength. Lighting
up dark data within your
organization similarly is something we're seeing
lots of customers doing.
Whether you've got information in
emails, in sales calls,
across some legacy systems within your
organization, being able to extract
information from those data sources
that was previously inaccessible
or invisible.
Workflow workflow augmentation
to actually reduce some
of that uh heavy lift is
another critical area where we're seeing
Gen AI really shine.
You can create,
you know, a collaborative loop where AI
executes on a tasks and humans
provide oversight, validation,
and actually input suggestions back
into your task in order to
improve that over time.
And finally, Gen AI can be used
to reduce the cost to serve
through strategic automation
where you have really well defined and understood
workflows.
So based on our work with customers
and we're these core strengths
that we're seeing, we've actually devised
6 product design strategies that we're
gonna detail today,
um, to you.
So with that I'll pass back to Eric.
Thanks Nicola.
So as Nicola mentioned, we're going to transition
into these 6 strategies in much more detail,
and I'd like to point out that profitable growth
was so important to what we're talking about today
that it actually made the session title.
This isn't just about building cool AI
features, it's about building things that will actually
help you make money as customers.
And before we dive into any technology
decisions, before we talk about tokens or vector
database optimizations,
we need to think about this fundamental question.
Will and how will
this AI capability actually
drive profitable growth for you
as an organization?
Because here's the thing, and we saw this with our fictional
healthcare company,
they learned it the hard way. They built something, but it
wasn't the right thing. You might have an impressive
AI feature, you might have a not impressive AI
feature if you're having people show up on a weekend.
But if users don't care about what you're building,
you're probably not building a sustainable business
model. I know that sounds obvious, but
many teams just kind of forget about that and get caught
up in all the hype of building something cool,
but ultimately you need to make sure that you're building
something that allows you to stay in business over
the long haul.
And a lot of times this is what we call the
technology driven approach that we'll talk about more on the next
slide. But the solution really
starts right here.
How can you build something that starts from customer
value, and then build that back into
every AI product decision?
So what does a technology driven approach look like?
It typically starts with this.
People follow a relatively typical
software design process, typically with a POC.
Maybe they come up with the use case first, maybe they bring it
up after the fact,
then they go through the subsequent design phases
to design, build, test, and deploy the
application. And at the very end you see over there
on the right side,
that's when they start thinking about price.
And what ends up happening, you start
hearing these from your customers. The ROI
isn't there, or it was a great demo,
but I'm just not willing to pay for it.
Or maybe
I like it, but I just can't justify the cost.
So what do teams do?
Well, maybe they release it as a premium feature,
hoping that somehow giving it away will ultimately
create the sustainable business model.
And that's exactly what happened to our healthcare
company. They built something, they released it.
But ultimately
their CEO was happy because they had AI in their product,
but it was the wrong thing for their customers.
So this backwards approach where we're building
first and figuring out how to price and how
to design value at the very end of the
process is kind of backwards.
So let's talk about a little bit of a better way.
While many of the core components of a value-driven
approach are the same, this is fundamentally
different. Instead of building and
then figuring out the pricing later, we're going
to start here by identifying high value
use cases.
Even as a techie myself, I know that oftentimes
it's, it's really important to focus not
just on the technology,
but really what is going to give my customer
value. This is going to deliver a meaningful
outcome for my customer and
make sure that there's something they're actually going to pay for.
This working backwards from customer requirements
is something that's near and dear to our hearts here at Amazon.
And what you'll notice is that early on in
the process here, we're going to develop a pricing
hypothesis.
And you can ask yourself at this point, are
customers willing to pay for this feature? And
that's not to say that you need to charge
for every single AI feature, and we'll talk more about
that in the next slide.
But you do really want to start with this early in the
process. We're shifting left this value proposition.
And then you can go ahead and still design, build,
and test and deploy your application.
But you're going to be making sure at this
point that you're doing this on the right thing.
I'd also like to call out the feedback loop at the
end, and it's important that this is not only a
technology feedback loop,
but it's also related to the value that we're
delivering for our customers.
We're making sure that as we're going through, we're
getting information from these customers
to see that we're we're getting the value that they
expect, and then we can adjust along
the way. If our healthcare
company had followed the same example, maybe
they would have picked something else to develop.
Maybe they'd have done something like automated insurance
claim processing or clinical note summarization.
But having this value-driven mindset is
really critical throughout the entire
process, and it's going to affect more than
just the technology decision, it's also going
to affect your product and go to market strategies,
which is what I'll talk about here on the next slide.
So when it comes to your go to market strategy, you
have 4 main paths forward that we've identified
here. Embed is the
first one. So if you think about this, it's
a defensive play. You're adding existing
AI features for your current customers,
and typically you're doing so without additional
charges.
This is often about protecting market share
and staying competitive in the marketplace,
and realistically this is what we see a lot of our customers
do today.
The one competitive differentiator you
have here though is your data.
And if you imagine, if you're an ISV that's
had
been operating over several years, you have all
this additional customer data that you can now
go and mine to make your
product even more competitive.
Think about a CRM provider that previously had
been working with financial analysts,
but now you can reach out to business analysts and
maybe interact with natural language processing.
Or maybe you're an HCM provider
and rather than having people create job descriptions
from scratch,
you now can give them some Gen AI capabilities, not
charge for it, but help with automated creation
of those opportunities.
The challenge here though is that you're giving them away, and that's
where we get into our next strategy around extend.
So extend is where the new money starts.
Effectively, you're adding some additional premium
features, but now you're doing so with an ability
to charge.
So if you think about maybe a collaboration
suite, rather than just sending messages,
maybe now you have a new AI capability where
you can go and summarize details or get
updates when you come back from vacation
and and be able to catch up a little bit more quickly.
But in this case, we're now
adding a new revenue stream and that's why we're calling
it extend.
But all these focus on
essentially
new features within kind of our
existing product.
When we start on the new product side.
Gonna Do that we're going to
refer to that as expand.
So this is a, a new market segment,
a new product for existing customers.
So if you think about my example of creating
new
job opportunities for a hiring manager,
that was really part of the core product. But what
if instead I could create a
new set of capabilities or a new product
to go out and actually screen candidates. So
I use AI to go out and do
some of the initial processing.
I've got a new value proposition. I'm
able to now have a new charging model
for that without affecting the base model.
And because of that,
again, I'm able to unlock additional revenue
for for myself as a company and then
give my customers additional value.
Then the last one we have is build. So this is
new products for new customers,
and, and this could be entering a totally
new space.
A lot of times this has the biggest risk
because you as an ISV might be creating
something brand new,
but it also can have the best reward
because now you're able to take some of the learnings that you
had in the past,
create a brand new offering, and then take that
to market with your customers.
But the interesting thing that stands out
to me as we look through all of these strategies is
that regardless of what you're choosing,
there's going to be that interaction between go to market
pricing and your product strategy.
And so because of that, we're also seeing
several several new pricing mechanisms
that have come out in the process.
So there are a lot more beyond just
these three strategies, and if you haven't seen it
out there, I'll give a shameless plug for our, our white
paper where we, where we're able to go into these in a lot more
detail.
Uh, but these are some of the 3 most common ones that we're
seeing out here in the industry.
Seat-based is likely what you're most familiar
with. It's what a lot of ISV customers use
today. And, and here we have a fixed cost per
user. There's some real positives to
that because we have
a consistent value that we're, I'm
sorry, a consistent price that we're charging our customers.
Our customers can plan for it, so there's
a lot of consistency,
but the problem that we have here is it doesn't
reflect the varying value that we're able to give
to our customers.
So if you imagine a power user is getting
a whole lot of value out of your AI
features and someone who is maybe
against AI or just doesn't know how to use it, they
might not be getting
any value or as much value.
And we're charging people the same amount. And
so not only does
that mean we're not getting the full value
from that,
it costs us a whole lot more to handle that
product uh power user than it
does someone that's a very light user. And so
there's a little bit of a difference from an economics perspective
as well. And that's where something like
usage or token-based pricing comes in.
This helps you as a customer align
your
consumption from your users to your actual
costs. And so from a unit economics perspective,
you're now much more in line with how
you're actually
accruing costs and giving value to users.
The downside there obviously is that there's a lot more variability,
and if your customers aren't used to buying this way,
that can lead to a little bit of
a transition as you make that change.
The last one I'd like to touch on is outcome or value
based pricing, and a lot of times we'll talk about these
differently, but for the sake of conversation today, I'll
include them together.
But here we're starting to see a lot more adoption
in the space, especially from a Gen AI
capabilities perspective.
Here you get paid based on the business value
that you're actually able to provide to your customers.
So imagine that I'm a
customer service, uh
uh software company and I'm able to.
Solve tasks for you. So a customer
puts in a support case. If I'm able to
solve it, you pay for it. It's typically a
fixed price for that action, so maybe
$1 per case that I'm solving.
If I solve it, you pay. If I don't solve
it, you're not going to be charged. And so there's
a really nice alignment to
customer value
and the actual pricing model.
Uh, Val base is a little different in that the
change there is that it's typically more variable.
So rather than just saying $1 per
action.
I'm going to take a portion of savings
or portion of revenue.
The example I like to think about is
I live in Texas. We have property tax valuation
every year, and based on
how much my
property taxes go up and down, that changes the amount I
pay. And so there's a company that works with me
to try and make sure that that value isn't too
high. If they save me money, they take a portion
of it, but our interests are really well aligned,
and I think that's a really nice example of value-based
pricing. But we talked
about working backwards, uh, and so
I don't just want to talk about what we see from
customers, but what are customers themselves actually
saying. So there was a, a
new study from IDC that went out there and asked
customers, what do you actually prefer when you're buying
AI capabilities?
And the way this study worked, as you can see, they asked
for their top 3 preferences, and it
resulted in a whole lot of interesting data.
We're not going to get into all those nuances,
but what I do want to show is some of the 3
more, or the 4 more prevalent ones.
So the top 2 pricing models were
were bundled premium tier subscriptions
and consumption-based pricing.
The next 2 favorite hybrid hybrid
subscription and usage models are flex credits.
But you see across that whole stack, there's
not really one that stands out.
And so despite
there being lots of different options,
depending on how you're providing those capabilities for
customers, depending on the value you're providing,
there's not going to be a one size fits all approach.
And so you're probably going to need to have some different monetization
techniques as you go along and customers
kind of make this transition with you.
But regardless of pricing,
you also need to keep in mind some of the cost
optimization capabilities, because obviously
if it costs you too much to provide this to
a customer, that's also not going to be sustainable and
profitable over the long term.
So what can we do from a cost optimization perspective?
Again, this is a small subset
of the many things that you can do,
uh, but a few things that I did want to call out, the
biggest option you have likely with Gen AI is your
model selection and customization.
So,
it maybe goes without saying, but don't just default
to the latest and greatest model because it
is the latest and greatest, it may also be the most
expensive.
Instead, you should pick the optimal model
for your specific use case.
Do validation with high quality data,
and then customize it to your business
specific requirements.
Oftentimes we find that a fine-tuned smaller
model or a distilled model can
perform just as well at a fraction of the cost,
and that's probably gonna be your biggest cost lover.
Also keep in mind token usage
optimization, and as you scale, these
can create big savings.
So analyze your token patterns,
implement token caching,
and ultimately that can help you not only improve
performance, but keep your costs in check.
I'll talk a little bit more about the appropriate pricing
plan when we get to the 3rd design strategy,
but I do want to mention vector database optimization
as the last piece that we'll talk about here.
As your data grows, this can be incredibly
critical to make sure that you're not overspending
from this perspective,
and you want to implement efficient chunking
strategies as you go along,
and especially as your vector database usage
improves. And remember, every dollar that
you save is either something that you can keep in your pocket
or pass back to your customers, so don't overlook
this as something to keep in mind.
But with that, I'll hand it over to Jeffrey.
Thanks, Eric.
So design strategy
zero critically important,
a business focused approach and one that that
understands how you're gonna drive profitable growth,
uh, right from the start
as we get into design, then,
uh, the, the, uh, the, the, the next strategy
that, uh, that, that, that we, uh, find that,
uh, successful companies use is
focusing on tasks over
conversations in a sense, not just going and building
that chatbot because it it seems like
the, uh, the right thing to do.
While conversational interfaces have
their place in certain scenarios,
task-oriented designs generally create
more valuable, trustworthy, and
successful generative AI features.
That's because they help customers, users
of your product, focus on specific goals,
and they also have clear inputs and outputs
which increases your chance of designing
a successful use case.
Um, they also define clear boundaries
for your interactions with AI, and
they, as part of that create natural
guardrails around the experience
that you're looking to create.
These guardrails help your product teams
address inconsistent or potentially harmful
outputs in the process.
A task oriented approach can
often turn out to be the most cost effective
because of the constraints
that are involved with the task-based design.
It's also easier to measure success
and iterate on your features when
you take that task-based approach,
and it makes it easier to implement
outcome-based billing if you want to implicate
implement some of those
newer pricing models. If you have
a clear definition of what the success
of the task is, then it's very natural
to be able to charge for it. For example,
processing a payment. The payment either goes through or the payment
doesn't go through, and you can charge on this
agreed success of that.
Also, a task-focused approach,
it makes it easier to extend existing
customer experiences
because they are often task-based interfaces.
So if you're using that first strategy
where you have an existing product and you're looking
to build new features for current customers,
extending the user interface with those
tasks can often be
very effective.
So if you are adopting a
task-based approach to the use case that you
want to implement, some things that you want to focus on,
facilitating the customer, the user's
agency and control,
you don't want to give them the blank screen. What should I
write? How should I talk to this
thing? You want examples
of things that the user can do,
highlight the insight
into the dark data that you're that you're
about to light up.
If you can personalize or contextualize
the task, uh,
if your use case can begin to predict
what the customer might want to do, the intents
that they want to fulfill,
like for example, if I'm booking a flight,
then can the system remember that I happen to be
a frequent flyer on American and
that I always fly out of Charlotte and
bring that context to the beginning
of the tax, the task processing
event. Um, finally,
uh, how are you gonna instrument the task
to make sure it's observable, to be able to
understand the level of successful completion,
uh, rates?
So just as an example of some of
these things, I worked with, uh, uh, an ISV
customer in the healthcare space,
uh, that makes information processing systems,
laboratory information management uh systems.
One of the things that they did was
to take an existing task that a customer
has reading lab reports.
Everybody knows, you know.
Figures come up. You look at it and you understand it
and you interpret the results.
They didn't want to change that fundamental task,
but what they did want to do is they wanted to
provide guidance by
an LLM to indicate the things that
the that the test reader should potentially
pay pay additional
attention to.
So by providing that additional
capability by being subtle
in the way that they presented the
information, they didn't overwhelm the existing
user agency agency, the existing
process that the lab tech would go through, but
they did allow them to sharpen their focus on the
things that might matter the most to them.
The result,
they saved an average of 2 to 3 minutes per
test read,
over hundreds of test reads a day,
significant productivity improvement
because they focused on the
task to start.
So some more examples of this,
uh, great example from a company called
Dovetail. We've got a few Dovetail folks in the audience
today. You guys put your hands up, yeah,
excellent. Um, Dovetail is a customer
intelligence platform. It aggregates, uh,
analyzes and shares qualitative data,
uh, from diverse
sources, uh, including customer interviews
and, uh, feedback, support tickets
and sales calls.
This example focuses on a specific
task that the Dovetail team,
uh, helps their customers with, which is theme
categorization across a broad,
uh, variety of, uh,
of, of, of data.
Now, uh, they do this via
a feature called channels
which automatically identifies and clusters
uh the themes across massive amounts
of data. So a good example of what Nicola said, lighting
up uh dark data.
It allows their customers to make
more informed decision making and allows
those companies to be more responsive to customer
needs and emerging trends, and this is the
important part. It saves hours
of manual analysis. So you've got toil
reduction there, and the net
is that it reduces the cost to
serve insights up from unstructured
data. So by organizing
around the tasks to be done by your
users as opposed to what kind of chatbot are
we going to build, you build a much more effective
interface for your existing
products. OK,
design strategy number 2 then, which builds
on that idea of a task-based
approach, focusing on narrowly
scoped tasks overbroad.
If you've spent any time uh
looking at the data that's come out recently, you've probably
run across the MIT NANDA report and
one of the things that they also picked up is one of
the reasons for so many failures
in the investments that organizations were
making was that when
organizations tried to implement
complex tasks that might span multiple
organizations or complex workflows,
uh, that uh usually those things were
harder to implement successfully,
so um.
In the case of the healthcare management
software company
that we talked about, if they had focused on
narrowly scoped tasks, they might have
had a higher rate of success. So examples like
verifying patient insurance eligibility
before scheduling an appointment, that's a narrowly
scoped task,
checking for drugs. Interactions when prescribing
new medications, that's a narrowly scoped
task,
generating patient friendly summaries of lab
results like the limbs example I just talked about,
that's a narrowly scoped task. It's going
to be much easier to successfully
implement those specific
use cases.
So the advantages of narrowly scoped tasks
include clear expectations of what
the AI should uh accomplish, which
makes it easier to set accuracy goals.
Uh, narrowly scoped tasks help
improve the response quality and the
reliability.
It also lowers the implementation risk
because it allows it, uh, it makes it easier
for you to do targeted evaluation
of, uh, how the LLM is responding.
It allows you to do precise testing
and more effective prompt engineering
around the task itself
and so it also makes it easier to
take each individually scoped feature
uh and evaluate it and refine it based
on your user feedback so it's not an all or
nothing when you go out to the customer and then
uh go into that that iterative
process of improvement
uh with your use case.
Let's look at a couple of really good examples.
I like to talk about Canva a lot
because they've
implemented AI capabilities
broadly across their product, but if you're a
creative user,
you might not even realize it because of the way
that they have integrated the task capability
into the overall flow
of the product. As an example,
Magicrite
generates specific text content like
headlines or captions.
The image generation tool that they have creates
virtual uh visual assets, uh,
that support particular design needs.
The chat assistants, uh, guides
users through specific creative
decisions. Each of those individual
features tackles one task,
and it does it really, really well.
Magic Rite doesn't try to be a good general
writing assistant. Its features are
specifically tuned for design-related
copy. So this
approach delivers two key benefits
for the Canva team.
First of all, the individual creatives
can easily understand what each feature does
and what outputs to expect, makes
it much more predictable.
Secondly,
uh, Canva can optimize
each individual feature
based on the use case, and the end result
is a higher quality experience for
their existing users, which incidentally
creates a higher price
performance opportunity
in the market.
Let me give you a second example. It's actually one that
we talked about earlier this week in one of the keynotes,
um. If you've
ever authored content that you want
to share with the world, you know that professional
book cover design can be a real barrier.
Kindle Direct Publishing sees this problem with
its customers.
It allows authors to self-publish
print and digital books that reach millions
of users on Amazon.
Now I wrote professionally for 16 years and I
can tell you that the creative process was
something that I practiced every day and I
got pretty good at writing,
but that didn't make me very good at uh
at graphic design,
uh, and, and, and I'm still not, uh,
indie authors face this problem all the time.
So what did the KDP team do?
Uh, it. Turned to the AWSACE
program, which is a program that we use to work
with customers around use cases,
specifically generative AI use cases,
and they came together to solve this problem in just
4 weeks.
They went from initial concept to a working prototype
and uh integrated with AWS Bedrock
as part of that and Adobe Firefly.
And so the specific task in this
case was the task of cover design.
By solving that distinct problem
with a very narrow scoped, manuscript
aware cover generation with commercial
IP protection,
the KDP team has transformed a long
standing pain point for folks like me
into competitive advantage as part of
the publishing process.
So that's design strategy too. Eric. I'm
gonna pass it back to you Jeffrey.
So now let's talk about the 3rd design strategy,
and in this case we're matching task modality
to requirements.
This is something that's gonna be that's gonna be
important no matter which of the product design strategies
you choose.
We find all too often that we just
default with our GI.
Gen AI experiences to be synchronous.
So users click a button, they start to see the
little spinner go, and then they wait for something
to happen.
It feels familiar because that's how we've often
designed our products in the past,
but it's not necessarily always the best fit when
it comes to generative AI.
And here's the problem, it often requires
higher performance characteristics than we
would need any otherwise, and it also then
results in higher inference costs.
So now you're forcing your users to wait,
and it's actually costing you more money.
Asynchronous design patterns are going to be
a slightly different way to do this. It's a fundamentally
different approach.
So instead of making users wait for that, you
can actually prioritize the next step in the workflow
and eliminate those forced wait times in the
process. So think about it this way, when
a user is waiting for some AI generated
content, whether it's a book cover,
ingesting
something else for your
operation. Do they really need to wait for that,
or could they move on and do
something else in the background while you're
waiting for the AI to complete this?
This not only improves the user experience, but
it actually addresses several several technical
challenges that I'll talk about in a slide or two.
So these are things like unpredictable
processing times,
resource management, and cost optimization.
So let's look into this in a bit more detail.
So when should you choose synchronous versus
asynchronous processing?
Synchronous processing, as you might imagine, are
things that require real-time interactions
or validation.
So if you're guiding a patient through onboarding
before they can see the doctor, that has to happen
before they can see the doctor.
Uh, it's great for simple queries where you have a predictable
response time, say less than 3 to 5 seconds,
or an interactive conversation, if you were actually
creating a chatbot, it would be a really bad experience
if you needed to go off in the background, let's just
say. For asynchronous processing,
these are going to have the opposite sorts of use cases.
So if you think about complex document
processing, if we were thinking about
processing insurance claims for our healthcare example,
this would not be a good fit
for synchronous, and so async is going to be our friend
here. And another case where we
might want to use asynchronous is if we have multi-step
workflows. So again, this is going to take a little bit
longer, it's a little bit more complex.
We don't need to sit there and have our user wait for this
to come back.
Another example where asynchronous is going to be a
good fit is where we need significant compute
power. So if it's going to take a lot of resources
to be able to complete this task,
it's something that we probably want to do in the background and then
let the user come back to it at a later point in time.
The key question you need to ask yourself is,
does the user absolutely have to wait for this
to to continue the next step in
their workflow?
If they do,
you're probably gonna need to go synchronous.
If they don't,
you definitely want to look at something like asynchronous
request for this.
One of the other benefits of using asynchronous
requests is that you can often get access to
lower priced inference.
So if you think about as of reinvent 2025
today on a Thursday,
a lot of our models have half
the cost if you're using batch inference as opposed
to on-demand.
And very,
very few other places allow you to save 50%
just by making a different design choice.
And we have other
AWS services that can help with that. If you think about
using SQS or EventBridge to allow
you to know what to do when someone triggers something
and then come back to it,
those are really good options to help you build these asynchronous
flows. So let's look at a real
world example from Tapi.
So, Tappy's a New England property management
start-up that's using asynchronous approaches to
help with automated invoice processing.
Here's how their solution works.
So a business will send an invoice to a
specific email address that Tay provides to
them. Then they use Gen AI in the
background to asynchronously process and extract
all the information that's contained within this invoice.
And this approach has 3 distinct
advantages that help address some of the challenges
that we see with Gen AI.
The first one is it tackles the latency
and performance unpredictability.
So model performance can vary
depending on the length. If you imagine I've got a short invoice
versus a long invoice,
the system loads, so how many invoices are coming in
at the same time.
And some of these things are going to be outside your control.
So by processing these invoices asynchronously,
Tapi's able to take that unpredictability
and kind of obscure it from their users, and
then turn it into a background process.
Their users aren't sitting there and waiting, and then they can
continue with the next step in the workflow.
Second, it provides security advantages.
So if you think about
asynchronous processing, you now have time
to be able to provide things like content filtering,
toxicity checks, and security chains
if you do want to have a human in the loop,
before you send it back to your users. So this
review before release model is a lot
harder to implement if you were using synchronous
processing. And third,
it enables resource management, and by that
I mean how can we best use the
resources available to us from our
G AI capabilities.
So we can do prioritization, we can implement
queuing systems. If we have a burst of load,
we can maybe spread those out over time if they all don't
need to happen at the same time.
And those are all things that would be really difficult
to do if we were using synchronous processing.
But probably most importantly,
this allows Tappy to give their users a better
experience and be respectful of their time.
So rather than sitting there and just again watching
that spinner go,
their users can move on to the next step. Maybe it's
sending in another invoice, maybe it's doing something
completely otherwise,
but they're not now
waiting for something
that needs to happen that isn't really required
from them. Uh, but with that, I'll
turn it over to Nicola for our last two strategies.
Thanks Eric.
All right,
so.
When integrating AI into your products,
how many of you got really excited and think
I'm gonna automate
everything? What happens
when with that automation, you're replacing,
you know, human intelligence and human nuance
and deep contextual understanding?
What happens when that fails?
We did see that in our hypothetical, thankfully
no customers turned up for their Phantom
appointments,
but you can see how you might end up
with really frustrated users who are
going to lose trust in your products.
So how can you avoid this?
Let's look at a real world example.
Vital is another New Zealand based start-up,
and they are revolutionizing patient
communication in inpatient
and hospital settings in the US.
So imagine this, you're a patient,
you've turned up to the ER and you're tracking
your your your visit
on your mobile phone.
A common problem is that you're gonna have a lot of tests
that get run.
And you know, the critical issue that
you're in there for is gonna be followed up, but what
happens if there's other incidental
findings that you might not
you might leave the hospital not knowing about?
Vital solution is to actually run
the patient notes and tests through
an LLM to extract those incidental
findings out of that information.
So, to be specific,
incidental findings are those
outside of what was primarily being looked for
within medical image reporting.
This again is a really classic example
of lighting up dark data.
You've got physicians that are able to validate
those findings,
they can streamline contacting the patient
and then update electronic health records
automatically.
With this workflow,
doctors provide that human touch
when they're delivering sensitive medical
information. And their expert feedback
can be used to further improve incidental
findings.
Currently, this product services over
3 million patients within the US
and they actually surface 94%
of incidental findings that would have
otherwise been unreported
and unnoticed.
Critically,
Vital estimates that this
feature would also take around 5
physicians
per hospital to actually implement.
So with AI they're actually unlocking
whole new capabilities.
Saying that,
Gen AI doesn't just augment
workflows,
it also gives you the ability
to create whole new workflows
that just weren't economically viable
previously.
Fundamentally, Vital have implemented
an augmentation loop, which is a pattern we're
seeing a lot of customers adopting.
Instead of fully automating the workflow,
they have AI generate the incidental
findings.
The clinician then verifies those findings
and is able to communicate to the patient
and provide feedback,
um, which then helps to
improve the accuracy
of those findings over time and build
trust.
So whilst full automation might seem
like the ultimate goal,
augmentation can actually
provide much more immediate value
and a better long-term result.
From a product perspective,
augmentation is also going to create
a much stickier experience,
because uh the clinicians in this example
or or your customers will build up
sort of muscle memory with your feature
over time.
This leads to higher engagement
as customers feel a lot more
competent and and able with your
product. Augmentation
can also create a much more forgiving
environment,
as you're able to
improve it iteratively over
time. You can launch the AR feature
without having full, you know,
expectation expectation of perfect
accuracy,
and users then provide the necessary feedback
to improve that over time.
This creates a really,
um, you know, important cycle of improvement
that pure automation is going to lack.
So let's breakdown that example
even further so you can see how
automation and augmentation can be
combined into one well-defined workflow.
Medical notes reveal
Gen AI. The incidental
finding is extracted also with Gen AI
before the patient is contacted for an examination.
Reminders can be sent.
There's a patient visit.
Notes are generated, uh, and
automatically updated in that patient record.
You can see here Gen AI is used
in uh to augment critical steps around
reviewing notes and extracting incidental
findings, and we've also got that clinical
expert at critical points,
you know speaking to patients about sensitive
findings.
We do also have automation. Involved,
so, you know, updating that patient record,
sending those reminders to the patient,
so you can see within this workflow we've
thoughtfully combined automation,
augmentation with AI
and including those those clinical experts
in the loop.
This thoughtful implementation also
addresses some of AI's biggest
weaknesses around accuracy and
consistency because you're catching any errors
you know before they really matter.
Let's drill down even further to see
how safety is further involved
within this loop.
So, this problem is broken
down into 3 overarching tasks,
let's think back to those, you know, previous strategies.
They've got clear inputs and they've got
clear outputs.
So, and multiple validation gates
within each.
The workflow is also an asynchronous
process.
So this provides time for guard rails
and checks to occur throughout that
process. Pre-processing
of clinical notes uses the Amazon Nova
Micro model for generating taxonomies
and pulling out relevant details.
Medical imaging has very specific taxonomies
that they're able to rely on here.
Myel actually migrated to Amazon
Nova Micro from a more expensive third
party model
when monitoring and testing showed that
they were able to perform the same
uh task with the same level of accuracy
at the fraction of the cost.
Every section is then validated against a
gold standard of taxonomies produced
by clinicians, so if something doesn't
match, it's gonna be discarded.
Rejectex is used to validate, you
know, do I actually have a response,
um, make sure that there's something there.
And then a lightweight AR model also validates
do I have something that's medically meaningful.
The core prompt generation is a bit more sophisticated,
so you've got
a a dynamically constructed
prompt, it's gonna include more patient
details around conditions,
medications, and also the reading level, so
who's actually gonna be reading this result?
This is before we also use an
uh LLM to actually judge the outputs.
So this is multiple prompts
included within this, it's gonna be looking at accuracy,
it's gonna be looking at safety.
Um, and the findings are actually
graded against a set of criteria that have
been validated by clinicians, so
if I'm getting a 5, it means it's highly accurate,
it contains the information that I expect it
to, down to a 1,
not so good, not so accurate,
we really need to review this for safety.
Studies by Vital have shown
that their in-house AI safety
uh evaluation framework has
achieved 99% accuracy.
So the clinician then reviews, oh
sorry, these uh findings
are then validated against a a
set of criteria,
so does it meet the safety threshold,
are there any sensitivity flags for the
types of results that are going to be uh
provided back to the patient.
And then anything that's particularly sensitive
will be sent to the physician to
review and then report back to the patient.
Citations and referencing to the original
reporting can also be included here
to help improve the accuracy of those
human reviews.
So these
checks and feedback can really be incorporated
again into any automatic evaluations,
which are gonna be critical for improving
your product over time.
But how do you know that this augmentation
loop is actually improving things
over time?
Monitoring is going to be your best
friend.
You need to track those business metrics
at a task level in order
to see that your feature is
actually incorporating all of that feedback
that you're being provided uh and and
collecting. Monitoring
becomes even more critical when you think
you know that the production environment is
not a static environment.
Models are gonna be deprecated. The
GPU allocations for the model
that you're using
might change, and maybe there's an
auto-upgrade of a model that affects accuracy
of the results that you're getting.
So here we have a very, very simple example,
it's not a real example from a customer.
I did make this using Quiro, but it is
representative of what I'm seeing with customers.
So you can track cost, which is, you know, a function
of the number of tokens and the cost per token,
as well as accuracy.
You may also be, you know, wanting to
track the execution metrics as well, they're
not, they're also very critical.
So if we go back to our extracting taxonomy
task,
what happens, you know,
when I introduce a change to that task.
So for example, what happens if I introduce
a new model?
Well you can see at this task level,
the cost is shifting down and the accuracy
is about the same.
So clearly it's a good um
a good change, a positive change,
uh, and I'm able to actually track this
easily because of the way I've set up my monitoring
and my metrics.
So remember our first uh strategy
about profitable growth.
Monitoring tells you if this feature is actually
becoming more profitable over time.
So when you can easily breakdown your cost
to serve at the task and at the feature level,
you can more easily set targets
around cost optimization,
uh, and actually implement some of
those strategies that Eric highlighted
uh earlier in the talk.
For those of you who are really really
interested in monitoring
and um automated evaluations,
I'd recommend checking out the Gen AI
Life Cycle Operational Excellence Framework.
Had to practice that one a few times.
Also GLOW, GLOE,
um there is prescriptive guidance around that that
goes into great detail.
So our final strategy
represents a real shift in
how we design for user experience.
Traditionally you'd optimize your interfaces
for human interaction.
So you want, you know, really clear visual
hierarchies, you want intuitive navigation.
But when designing your experiences
for LLMs you're now saying,
oh the AI is the intermediary
between my customer and the
product. When an LLM
is consuming and processing
information uh from your product, it's
not gonna care about where is
that button on the page, what color is it,
uh, instead it needs structured,
predictable and semantically
rich data formats.
This means designing your API's
and your data schemas and your system outputs
with machine interpretation in
mind. So remember our
healthcare company, you know, way back at the
start of the presentation.
Instead of that
Interesting chatbot,
imagine if they designed for their appointment
system with both humans and AI
in mind,
with structured data to prevent phantom
appointments from appearing and clear
schemas to help
AI understand availability
constraints, so we're not getting our Saturday
appointments booked in.
Amazon maintains a relentless focus
on the architectural principles that
enable rapid scaling and innovation.
One of the most transformative decisions
that was made
was to have all teams expose their
data and their functionality through APIs.
This was about creating a company where any
team could build on top of the work of
another team.
The API first approach
enabled Amazon to launch
AWS so we can thank that
for our conference today,
um, and Amazon had solved the
problem of making internal systems
accessible.
Every service was able to
become a product.
So just as Amazon's API mandate
broke down internal silos,
MCP servers breakdown the silos
between AI models and the tools that
they need to actually be useful.
Model context Protocol or MCP
makes it easy for products to expose their
functionality directly to AI,
um, directly to AI agents
through a standard interface.
So a lot of definitions have been thrown
around about agents, I'm sure you've heard many
this week,
um, but the one I like best is that
agents
are models using tools
in a loop.
Can't take credit for that one, I did hear it on
Simon Willison's blog, I believe it's via
anthropic.
So,
how can you actually
set up your applications to
allow these agents easy access?
One way companies are doing this is through
MCP.
Companies are also doubling down on
really rich APIs with good documentation.
API's using open API format,
uh, open API schemas
already have a really familiar,
uh, syntax for tool calling.
Uh, and they can easily be modified
to be used by LLMs.
So we're witnessing a shift from optimizing
solely for that user experience to
including the LLM experience
or LLMX.
This transition is apparent in how you
approach your documentation, so you
know, think of the days of having,
you know, scattered PDFs,
video tutorials, help docs, FAQs,
you know, across your whole organization
really are ending as LLMs need comprehensive
and structured documentation
that they can rapidly pass.
So moving to markdown based documentation
is isn't just about convenience,
it's also about having machine readable
content that seman that has, you
know, the clear semantic structures and
human but still remains
human friendly.
Well structured markdown allows for
LLM's to understand relationships
between concepts and the logical
flow of how your product is meant to work.
So think of your documentation as training
material for any uh AI
agents that are going to be using your
product. You've created
comprehensive knowledge bases that
AI can instantly access and then
synthesize in order to
provide relevant guidance.
The product,
the products that are able to master this
LLM experience will have AI
AI agents that can expertly navigate
their products from day one.
But how do you reimagine how
users are going to interact with your software
in this transition from UI,
sorry, from UX to LLMX?
This shift requires thinking beyond
traditional app boundaries that we're all
used to.
So let's use an example.
Let's consider how I might interact with a
location service. I'm gonna open up a
location, you know, I'm very new to Vegas,
so I, I, I'm looking for everything at the moment.
I might search for a place that I wanna find,
I might switch to another panel, try and
find other places that are nearby,
uh, and then click through to find a bit more
detail about those options.
You can see I've probably navigated through multiple
different UIs and different interfaces
in order to get the information that I need and
there's friction at every point.
AI AI agents using
tools and MCP servers can
coordinate these tasks for me simultaneously.
There's no need to click through different user
interfaces as an agent is able
to see which MCP servers and tools
are available in order to complete that
task for me and present it back.
So as a user, I can specify
where I wanna go,
and that agent might use say Amazon
location MCP to
find uh nearby
options for me
uh without me needing to go through that
visit. It can then be
presented back to me in a readable
format, um, so that human
experience is still very much a part of it here,
um, without me having to traverse
through multiple UI's and have multiple
points of contact.
So the challenge becomes to think about creating
capabilities that AI can invoke
um rather than products
where
that are destinations for users.
This requires thinking beyond the traditional
UIUX
and focusing on making your product's core
value and core features
accessible through intelligent orchestration.
So with that, I will pass back to Geoffrey
to round out our presentation.
Thanks, Nicola.
So
that is a pretty broad tour
through a lot of things that when you
apply each of these collectively
and you stack them as you can see in the
examples how one over after another
uh uh another after another stack
can yield
meaningful differences
in the use cases that you're looking to automate.
Drive down the cost and enable
you to, in a very stepwise fashion
reach profitable growth and
increase your odds of success,
beat the odds uh from what the surveys
are telling you.
Drive profitable growth with a value driven
approach. It starts with the business case.
Focus on tasks over conversations,
narrowly scope those tasks. Make
sure you pick the right modalities which are gonna
help you optimize the right cost and
optimize the way your customers interact
with what you're building.
Favor augmentation over automation.
And design your experiences for both
humans
and uh for LLMs
do those and you're gonna find that that
your your uh chances of
of of delivering meaningful
uh interactions with your
customers, driving meaningful extensions
to your product and driving profitable growth
are gonna become a lot easier.
So with that we want to thank you for joining us. We'll
hang around afterwards if there are any
questions, uh, if you're interested in
diving deeper,
uh, you can start with the QR code there
which is gonna take you, uh, to, uh,
the follow up material that we have that, uh,
that will help you, uh, expand on the design
practices that we've presented here.
Also, um, we have
programs within the. ISV segment
uh that are designed to help organizations
walk through those use cases to score
them, to understand
where you might want to focus your effort and your
AM can help you uh understand
things like the generative AI innovation Center,
uh, the agentic Catalyst program,
uh, ways that we can help accelerate
working through these design best practices,
uh, and, uh, and, and, and we're
looking forward to, uh, to helping you get on
that path, uh, to profitable growth.
Uh, last thing,
uh, if you, uh, have the opportunity,
make sure that you continue your learning journey
on, uh, uh, AWS SkillBuilder,
uh, especially around these topics with
respect to generative AI.
So with that, thank you, have a great day,
hope you have a great rest of the conference and
thanks guys, we'll stay around.